[MUSIC PLAYING]
HONG CHING GOH: What
is a mangrove forest?
Mangrove are the
only forests found
on the edge of the sea in
warm sub tropical and tropical
environments.
They can be easily recognized
by the dense tangle
of [INAUDIBLE] roots that make
the trees appear to be standing
on stilts above the water.
Mangrove are a
valuable resource.
They are estimated to
provide at least $1.6 billion
annually in
[INAUDIBLE] services,
the multiple benefits
that humankind
enjoys from ecosystems.
This value is in the realm of
national GDP's such as that
of the Virgin Islands.
In recognition of the
significance of mangrove,
the Ramsar Convention for
conservation and sustainable
utilizations of mangrove
was signed on the
February 2nd, 1971.
February 2nd has been
declared World Wetlands Day.
A unique mix of marine
and [INAUDIBLE] species
live in mangrove ecosystems,
especially in Asian region.
The calm, sheltered waters
among the mangroves' roots
provide breeding, feeding,
and nursery grounds
for fish and anthropoids.
Herons, spoonbills,
and even eagles
make their nests in the upper
branches of mangrove trees.
Reptiles are plenty.
Mangrove play a very important
role in soil formation
and shorelines protection.
Their unique above
ground root structures
dampen watered currents.
They also reduce the
impact of strong winds
and tidal wave that
accompany tropical storms.
Mangrove are among the
most carbon rich forests
in the Tropics, containing
an average 1023 mega grams
carbon [INAUDIBLE],
at least three times
that of the upper
tropical forests.
Mangroves' wood is
most commonly used
as a source of fuel
for local communities,
and as the primary construction
material for boats, houses,
and furniture.
In addition,
mangrove [INAUDIBLE]
fisheries, the main
source of livelihood
for many local communities.
Mangrove also contain
great medicine
of value including [INAUDIBLE],
bleeding and malaria,
to name a few.
Cannonball mangrove
fruit, for instance,
is used to treat diarrhea.
In many parts of the
world, mangrove also
bear great cultural significance
for local communities,
such as the indigenous
peoples of the Torres Strait
Islands, who have used
Australia's mangrove for more
than 40,000 years.
Despite its importance, the
rate of mangrove deforestation
is among the highest
of any forest type.
And urbanization
has been identified
as a significant
threat to the survival
of these coastal flagship
natural resources.
Urbanization refer
to the concentrations
of human population
into discrete areas.
Cities, leading to the
transformations of land.
It is a global phenomenon that
is intensifying especially
in low and median
income countries.
Today, half of the
world's populations
live within 60
kilometers of the sea,
and three quarters of
all the largest cities
are located on the coast.
While cities foster
economic, growth,
and offer the vast majority
of employment opportunities,
urbanization also brings
congestion and pollution.
It also escalates [INAUDIBLE]
such as displacements
of native peoples
and urban poverty.
The fundamental
change it causes,
however, is the
transformation of nature.
Globally, urban development
is the major driver
of climate change, producing
half of all greenhouse gas
emissions.
Luckily, land in coastal
area is reclaimed
for property development,
and mangrove forests
are transformed into
open water fronts.
Malaysia is a median
income country
located in Southeast Asia.
We have a total coastline
of 4,675 kilometers.
In these coastal
areas, mangrove forests
are found, which,
at the end of 2006,
were estimated at 107,802
hectares in Peninsula Malaysia
alone.
Today, very few mangrove remain.
Over 18% of the mangrove were
lost between 1975 and 2005,
primarily due to conversions
of land for agriculture, shrimp
ponds, or open development.
Johor, Malaysia's
southernmost state,
is home to more than a
quarter of the total remaining
mangrove in Peninsula Malaysia.
Is also home to
[INAUDIBLE] areas
of international importance
for conserving biodiversity.
All three of these
[INAUDIBLE] are located
within Iskandar Malaysia.
Established in 2006,
Iskandar Malaysia
is a national special,
economic region,
located in southern Johor,
just across the straits
from Singapore.
It is modeled the Pearl River
delta economic zone of China,
with the purpose to
capitalize on its existing
synergies with Singapore.
The region has a
land size that is
three times that of Singapore,
and is administrated
by the Iskandar Regional
Deferment Authority,
or [INAUDIBLE].
The indigenous group
around [INAUDIBLE]
once practicing a
nomadic lifestyle,
have settled down along the
southern coast of Johor.
They live in coastal
areas and river estuaries,
and like many
other local people,
are dependent on mangrove
for their livelihood.
Today, mangrove conservation
in Johor is becoming critical.
With fast phase
urbanization taking
place in Iskandar Malaysia,
local and indigenous groups
dependent on mangrove
face the truth
of losing their homes
and source of livelihood.
Iskandar Malaysia aims to
be a strong and sustainable
metropolis of
international standing.
To support this vision, three
mangrove management strategies
can, and should be pursued.
Strategy one.
Ecotourism as a mangrove
environmental service.
An ecotourism project
in Iskandar Malaysia
has been launched in 2013.
However, it was limited to a
single village Kompang Sona
Melayu, at the Melayu River.
Meanwhile, a study on tourism
potential of the [INAUDIBLE]
region was conducted in 2010,
but the actual implementation
has not taken place.
It is promising that tourism,
with education at its core,
can be ecologically and
economically beneficial
to local villages.
However, this strategy
and its benefits
must be shared by
more communities
to include both the local
and indigenous people
in the [INAUDIBLE] district,
along [INAUDIBLE] River,
as well.
In addition, capacity building
for tourism operations,
and the linkage between
local businesses and tourism
networks at the state
level must be established.
For this, the Ministry
of Tourism and Culture
must take the lead in working
with all relevant stakeholders.
Strategy two.
Technology for
mangrove monitoring.
The applications of
GRS and remote sensing
in mangrove management
must be incorporated
in the existing
manual monitoring
practices by the Johor
forestry department.
These technologies are
powerful at systematically
and periodically measuring
the effectiveness
of ongoing management practices.
Subsequently, this provides
a more defensible basis
for management actions
towards conservation.
SPEAKER: Remote sensing is
one of the latest technology,
I wouldn't say latest
because it is there
in the market since 1970s,
is the only practical way
to get rapid information
about mangrove changes.
HONG CHING GOH: Strategy three.
Core management for
mangrove governance.
The institutional structure
for managing natural resources
in most developing countries,
including Malaysia,
is based on a top down approach,
and is very much development
driven.
In light of sustainable
city's development objectives,
and the current state
of mangrove destruction,
combination among interdependent
governance structures
is the core of effective
mangrove management.
As land is prescribed
as state matter
under the federal
constitution, the agencies
dealing with mangrove, such as
the Department of Environment,
are merely technical advisers
reviewing land development
proposals.
They have little power
when it comes to land
development decision making.
It is recommended that these
agencies be given more power,
and be directly involved in
the decision making process.
Moreover, [INAUDIBLE] impact
assessment requirement
must be strictly enforced.
At the local level, the Iskandar
regional development authority
has initiated efforts to
include local communities
in mangrove
conservation projects.
However, the scope
of participation
is confined to
public [INAUDIBLE]
and the capacity
building related
to resource consumption.
MADAM IVY WONG ABDULLAH:
Within IRDA we've
got a social development
division that works closely
with the communities to
ensure that whatever economic
development that we
bring to the region,
it needs to have the
inclusion of the people.
For example, closely to mangrove
communities is the [INAUDIBLE]
so we have been working
closely with them
for the last few years to build
the capacity of the community
in arranging visits by tourists
to the surrounding mangroves.
So boat visits to the mangrove
forest, and also to the kelong,
where the community is rearing
mussels, green mussels,
and also some fishes.
So I think the sea
bass and all that.
We're working with the
people because there's
a platform that was created,
Friends of Iskandar Ramsar,
to work with them in carrying
out educational research
programs.
HONG CHING GOH:
It is [INAUDIBLE]
that the level of
participations amongst
local and indigenous
communities be expanded,
and that they are not only
given the rights to use
mangrove resources as
granted by the authorities,
but also the rights to
take part in managing
those resources together
with government agencies.
For that, core management
becomes a viable means
to bring all
stakeholders together
despite their
different interests.
Here, finding the right
mix of stakeholders
to govern the resources
becomes the key.
The Senai Pulai Forest
Reserve, an area
in urgent need for
protected area status,
provides a example of the need
for a core management strategy.
At present, harvesting this on
a 20 years rotation schedule,
is the major economic
activities here.
The mangrove management
plan is outlined
in the overall forestry
management plan
but this will expire in 2015.
VINCENT K.K. CHOW:
If it is talking
about the role of
the forestry, I
think they're doing
a very good job.
Although you see
mangrove being cut,
but this is on rotation
basis, small areas where
the concessionary will replant.
So the only fear is the
original species maybe
wiped out because they're
going to mono-cropping.
HONG CHING GOH: Therefore,
the preparations
of a comprehensive
management plan specifically
for mangrove forest
is urgently needed
to indicate the
permitted land uses,
the carrying capacity
of those uses,
and the stakeholders
that need to be involved
in the management process.
Apart from the tree
shortages just described,
the potential for
moral considerations
and religious values to play a
unifying and revitalizing role
in mangrove conservation, and
nature conservation in general,
must be further explored
in development planning
and at the societal level.
In fact, a holistic
approach to land
use development planning, known
as the total planning doctrine,
was introduced in the mid-1990s
by the federal government
of Malaysia.
It aims to integrate
physical and social planning
with moral and spiritual values.
However, little evidence
shows the implementations
of the approach in reality.
At the societal level, the
dominant religious customs
have been still mainly confined
to discrete practices, rather
than a way of life,
which has the potential
to cultivate a direct
connection between humans
and the environment.
WAN MOHD YUSOF WAN
CHIK: [NON ENGLISH]
HONG CHING GOH:
Urbanization is one
of the most complex
and important
social economic phenomena
of the 21st century.
It is forceful, irreversible,
and constantly evolving.
It also represents a major
change in the extraction
and consumptions of
nature resources,
and the way that society
interacts with nature.
Yet, if we only see
cities as a problem,
we fail to recognize how cities
offer improved quality of life,
and serve us the
centers for culture.
The strategies
recommended in this video
for mangrove governance
in Iskandar Malaysia
incorporates a wide range of
appreciations for mangrove.
This [INAUDIBLE] the quest
for a meaningful practice
of sustainable
urban development.
At the regional level
the strong presence
of mangrove and
indigenous people
presents an opportunity
for Iskandar Malaysia
to be a unique living model
of a developing countries that
substantially improve the
metropolises by making
the relationship between nature,
culture, and view environment
a synergized and symbiotic one.
At the national level,
mangrove conservation
directly supports
Malaysians' efforts
to reduce carbon emission in
light of the global climate
change agenda.
So are there
strategies likely to be
useful for other cities facing
similar development driven
challenges?
Yes, they are.
These studies is an
example of [INAUDIBLE]
learning by sharing
lessons and ideas
through digital communication.
Similar to the case of Iskandar
Malaysia, many emerging
cities in developing countries
are rich in natural resources
and culture, and striving
for economic development
has put tremendous pressure
on these precious assets.
Meanwhile, transparency
has been a key concern
in developing countries.
Yet little evidence reveals
that transparency alone
can make a significant
contribution
towards sustainabilities' goals.
Benefits sharing and
capacity building,
as highlighted in the
mangrove management strategies
in this video,
are believed to be
the enabling factors
for transparency
to achieve its effect.
However, the prioritizations
of these strategies
require careful considerations
of the past and present,
political and social
cultural context of the city,
as well as the state
and the ideologies
behind the region's economic
development activity.
Bye bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]